[Musique]
tu sais que la jungle fait partie de toi
mais explorer n'est pas un jeu et tu
ne regardes pas avant de sauter d'
accord mais nous sommes sur quelque chose de grand Dora
une ville ancienne faite d'or mais à propos de
ça et ta mère et moi  tu vas le
prouver
Amy, je suis désolé ma chérie tu ne vas pas avoir l'
air d'être dans la ville avec des enfants de
ton âge comme Diego pourrait aider
vas-tu être invité à certaines de ces fêtes
appelées viols la musique sonne comme ça
fais attention  c'est ce que nous voulons
dire cousin Diego
tu es tellement maigre et coriace tu es bien
plus énergique que je me souviens
Dora ce n'est pas la jungle c'est le
lycée c'est la vie ou la mort fais profil bas
juste et sois cool porte d'accord qu'est-ce qui est  cette
[musique]
où avez-vous transféré de la jungle
voici l'équipe de la liste de chasse au trésor
en groupes de quatre hola Dora
vous nous aiderez à trouver vos parents et la
cité d'or perdue où sommes-nous tous je vois la
jungle voir trois mercenaires armés  Oh
regarde Dora a apporté un couteau lors de la sortie sur le terrain
ev  tous ceux qui voudront peut-être
partir et nous sommes avec vos parents
vous êtes tous en danger nous allons mourir
ici il n'y a pas besoin de réagir de manière excessive
bien sûr elle connaît ce singe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je dois continuer  peu importe ce
qu'elle est géniale, je pense que nous sommes en
sécurité
[Musique]
ce film n'a pas encore été noté